hey youtubers is Charlie so all the
Justice League actors have been teasing
some stuff from each of their characters
for the film Henry Cavill naturally not
to be left out teased his black costume
from the return of Superman arc in the
comics so there's going to be a
breakdown to that so what are you
looking at here well it just looks like
the Under Armour tight costume that Zod
was wearing during Man of Steel but you
know obviously you get the reference to
the return of Superman after the death
of Superman arc because Superman died
during the end of Batman vs Superman but
we know that he's coming back to life
like that was the whole reason for
seeing get hit with that nuclear missile
blast like he turns into this corpse in
space gets hit with the sun's rays and
then booms regenerates right back so
while it is still question as to whether
or not someone digs up his body and then
it gets hit with sunlight and comes back
or if like the solar radiation is just
like slowly seeping through the soil at
a very very slow rate just making his
regeneration take longer
he will regenerate and come back but we
didn't really see I don't think we
actually did see what garb he was buried
in but you can see just the level of
detail they go in with these costumes
like this is just the beginning this is
just like a small tease of it the
Kryptonian costumes from the beginning
of man is still give you a better idea
for that just very elaborate very alien
looking but if you're wondering what the
color actually is it's much closer to
the color of Zod's costume so you can
think of it as like the black Superman
Returns costume which is not the last
time that he's worn a black costume in
the comics so if you remember during the
new 52 Andy Diggle tried to do a run of
action comics where he wanted to chop
Superman's arm off people were like hard
pass not going to let it fly bro they
teased a black costume during that run
there's even this picture here where
he's flying it like he looks super
hardcore kind of evil looking it was
part of that aborted run that they later
repurposed as part of the Lois and Clark
rerun when Dan Jergens came back on
after conversions so in the last year
there's been a lot of crazy stuff
happening with the Superman character in
the comics I know there's been a lot of
confusion so there's like a Chinese
version of Superman the Superman from
new 52 has supposedly died the
post-crisis Superman has come back he
has a child with Lois Lane they're still
married they're like
a happy family but he's been in hiding
this whole time the new 52 has been
going on so there's a lot of confusion
with what's going on with the Superman
character don't worry about it
you don't need to read any of the comics
to understand what's going on with the
movies but I would recommend just for
fun that you go back and read that
return of Superman arc it's a very
different type of Superman like you can
see the way he's written here he sounds
more like a Marvel character Superman
but with guns
he's very 90s tank it was just meant to
refresh the character like oh we'll kill
him off we'll bring him back he'll be a
whole different person
he won't be your dad's version of
Superman he actually spun off into a
later arc where he looks like he's drawn
by Rob Liefeld like look at all these
pouches this was actually from an arc
when Superman went on a space hunt so it
just is funny to see all the different
changes in the characters over time it's
the same thing for all comic book
characters but there have been a couple
times where he's worn a black costume in
the comics the only one I think the
movie will reference though is the
return of Superman following the death
of Superman art but as you can see like
right around comic-con they dropped this
picture of the Justice League obviously
this is a photoshop job all these actors
weren't standing next to each other on
screen it's a bunch of different
pictures cobbled together but it's an
official artist's rendering of what the
Justice League will look like in the
movies like Warner Brothers released
this but this is what Superman's costume
is going to look like when he puts on
the classic blue costume but for a brief
period it just seems like they're
teasing he's going to be wearing that
black Kryptonian garb here's the big
question though when he comes back do
you think he will have grown a beard
because I know a lot of you been making
jokes about mullet Superman which was
the haircut that he came back with
during the return of Superman it was the
beginning of mullet era Superman they
were using the whole arc as a way to
refresh the character design so he went
on to have a mullet for a while before
they cut the hair short again this is
Superman pre casket let me know if you
think they're going to bring him back
with with like overgrown hair and a
beard because his hair still grows like
a normal person's wood but because he's
so strong he can only cut it with his
own heat vision if you ever wondered how
Superman cuts his hair he does it with a
mirror and very careful use of his heat
vision but in the context of the movies
there are two other things that we know
of they can cut in besides the
Kryptonian spear Wonder Woman's sword is
capable of piercing
skin into Aquaman strident but I
wouldn't be surprised if the minute that
he comes back the first time you see him
on screen again
he has grown something of a beard this
is what he looks like in the Man of
Steel movie so he actually looks pretty
good with the beard on so while I'm not
really expecting him to resurface to
like the third act of the fit like it's
gonna be a while like we're probably
going to meet the villains before we
meet Superman again so like something
really crazy happens the Justice League
comes together get their asses handed to
them then boom the ringer gets kicked
back into the game and they take down
Steppenwolf in a way that teases that
something even worse might be coming
like Darkseid for a future sequel so we
go from regenerating Superman to Super
beard in the black costume to Superman
back in the blue you know maybe slightly
tweaked version of the costume it does
seem like there's going to be a slight
evolution of all the costumes just like
a little bit because they tease that the
Batmobile like Batman will react to the
threat that's coming and realize that he
has to adapt so he just cranks
everything to 11 so spoilers for Suicide
Squad excited to talk about that movie
just a little bit so here we go so the
flash appeared during Suicide Squad and
it looked like he had the costume that
he's wearing the Justice League trailer
so they've been teasing that Batman
because he's Bruce Wayne he has billions
of dollars is going to be funding this
team meaning that most of his upgrades
will come via Wayne tech I wouldn't be
surprised if STAR Labs got involved too
because mother box cyborgs way more
advanced than anything that Wayne tech
has their hands on but because we're
talking about Superman Kryptonian
technology would it not be crazy if at
some point in the movie you know some
point in the far future we get to the
actual watchtower satellite and it ends
up being like this hybrid of Wayne tech
in Kryptonian technology because we've
already seen that Lex Luthor was able to
interface with the Kryptonian ship so
it's not too far for each to say that at
some point they'll find some Kryptonian
tech and use that to build a really
badass base in outer space but again I'm
not expecting to see the watchtower in
the movies any time soon at least till
like the second maybe even third Justice
League film so any special base that
they will have for the meantime will be
the Batcave like when we see Wonder
Woman and Batman joking in the Justice
League trailer they're in the back
so just continue to use the bat-cave for
the meantime but if you guys didn't see
my last video I talked about the
Punisher season 1 they just confirmed
that it's going to be dropping in 2017
so I'll be doing a video about that next
James Gunn was also teasing that he's
been offered a lot of DC films and
declined so I'll talk about those too he
also said there were a couple DC movies
that he did want to make so all that
stuff's coming next be sure to subscribe
to get it there is a new round of the
giveaway - all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video there'll be some more TV
show flash stuff happening this week -
I'm expecting a couple more TV trailers
in the next couple weeks while you guys
wait for that to post we may have found
cable for the Deadpool and cable sequel
movie that they're making you can click
here to learn all about that and you can
click here for all my other Justice
League videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you